A  SURVEY ON
AND DIMINATION
A NONPROFIT GROUP FON HEALTH CT
SIAN
NA TO E U.S.
US
MIT, THEYLOOK TO SAVE OFF POTENL
VISITS.TMENT DURINALTH
60%  PPLSERVED52 AMERICAN --
, 51, 42%
OF ASIANSAPREPARE TO HEATH THE E
TREATED FAIRLY AT LEAS
IN
IS  ARTEAGA,
EQSAMANTHA, YOU FOR BEING
.MESOME
AREW
YO LEA ATHIS CRYTHAT THEH
SURVEY FINDING WAS REALLY
MI THE
U.S. TODAY.
HOW THOSPERIENCES EXTENDH CAREPE
HEE AS WELL ASULTIMATELY THEIR .
AS YOU, NTD
FINDINGS HIGHLIGHTEDEXENISPEOPLN
BEFORE DOCTOR'CEPRE VISITS,
CONCERNED ABOUT NG INSULTS
THE DOCTOR'S OFFICE,SE BEINGAT E
INAN
THEY  EXPERIENCES IN THDOCTORSE
PROVIDER NOT TAKING THEIR
NOT
SWRESPON TO A REQUEST,
BLAMTHORH ISSUES,
ORN
MEDICATION THAT THEY THOUGHT
>> WHAT'S INTERESTING I D
MINORITY RESPONDENTS DID NOT
THINK THAT IT WOULD BE
ER IF THE HEEOVIDER SHARE FOR
ETHNICITY. IS NOT A WHITE PROVI,
ACK PATI, E
MEDICAL SERVICESNDN, ATIENT ASR.
EVENIAT
SURVEY RESPONDENTAT THEY DID TO
COLOE HE, WHOSEE IN TH IS THAT W
ARES THE RACIAD
BACKGROUNDS, TAVING
FENUL INTERACE PROVIDER, SO
THE SURV DO
TO SOME POTENTI
OPPORTUNITIES, AND BENEFITS
FROMS TOIMOVE DIVERSITY OF THE
HETH BUT WE
THE IMPORTANCE OF CONTUEING EDU.
AND I T TAKE
THAT FINDINGR THAT
AGAINST E
SPECIFICALLY IN FLORIDA
GR RON DE WE FUNDED
D EQUITY AND
INCLUSION PROGRAMST  LEARNING I.
THE SUSTES IS RELYNYLESST
LENGES.
OVERALL, I INSUINGS REALLY POIE
ANCE OF IMPORTED --
TO ADD R
TION, RTNARE.
TH STH RACISD
DINAON JUST A
SOCISS A HEALTH
ISSUE.
YO TINS REFLECTEIN, THEY ALSGHE
INSC HEALTH AND
PPLO
PEDISCRIMINATION IN THEIR
LIFE, WHICH REMAINEQMO LIKELTOTE
DEPREN AN
THERE ARE HEALTHMPACTS ALS